258 ses chéris c'est le nombre de faux
permis qui ont été vendus d'après 90
minutes enquête hier soir sur tmc ça a
très bien marché
bref sans 3903 mythes et les spectateurs
le thème de l'émission était accident
faux permis et délit de fuite on a
l'impression d'avoir vu mille fois
encore ça on avait normalement qu'on l'a
vu pendant 150 ans mais dans l'émission
ils ont parlé des faux permis de
conduire et ce phénomène ne touche pas
uniquement des anonymes mais aussi des
personnalités
au total 258 faux permis sont vendus y
sont vendus entre autres à des stars qui
a déjà conduit sans permis après il faut
pas le faire un mois jean michel maire
je sais puisque la police m'a appelé
dans la série ouais d'ailleurs à chaque
fois vous fait une connerie
si les gens pouvaient éviter de mal
c'est à dire voile haute ils y font pas
très content que ma peau mais lui il
vous plaît vous n'arrêtez pas de dire
que vous êtes un peu comme notre père
oui évidemment le réflexe d'appeler son
père
si vous cherchez un peu comme votre père
vous et moi on verra conjoint ou daf et
son conjoint quand tonelli aurait adapté
ses tarifs au niveau de fortune de ses
clients il revend très cher entre 5,6
8010 1000 euros parfois il les revend à
des sportifs
il y a aussi des people comme ali baddou
l'ex animateur de canal+
mais aujourd'hui il ne souhaite plus
évoquer la sphère ne vous ai bien ali
baddou on fait un reportage à propos des
faux permis je voulais savoir si vous
pouviez nous expliquer un petit peu ce
qui s'était passé rigou la très belle
série se rappelait ali baddou pour faux
permis mais name et dans le reportage et
malgré ont également toutes les façons
pas légal de camoufler la voiture ce qui
a gonflé sa plaque d'immatriculation
et on sait pas repéré par les radars la
laque vous des techniques différentes
vous conduisez virginie way ses rivaux
si axel
moi j'ai plus qu'à un point dont j'ai
arrêté vous avez quoi vous plaît
attendez tranquillement qu'on aime parce
que j'ai fait beaucoup de stages gens
qui ont fumé ouais non mais elle a passé
sa vie est à dire quand on cherche
accède à pons 3 quelle au stade donc là
vous ne conduisez points moi je sais pas
je sais c'est assez déprimant shawey
âgées chez qui j'avais fait mon café des
stages de la wii
tu l'as fait aussi l'objet et deux jours
d'école oui et vous vous avez fait des
stages de mariage dont les coûts des
stages de permis de conduire ah ouais
mais c'est assez c'est assez pénible